what a gorgeous herbaceous mentaly
there's been a mistake you've
accidentally given me the food that my
food eats salad is traditionally the
first course at a wedding is a gerbil
marrying a rabbit I'm in charge of food
for the wedding so I brought in pawnees
three best caterers and a panel of
experts chris loves vegetables Ron loves
meat and Tom considers himself a foodie
which apparently means taking instagrams
of food instead of eating it okay so I
liked number one Chris liked number two
and Ron liked number three Tom what
about you cater number ones presentation
was simple yet exhausting
number two's was subtle and provocative
like a coy Dutch woman guarding a dark
secret nothing you're saying is helpful
but number three's told a story a story
from a book I wouldn't read but I would
watch the movie of that's nonsense you
know what I'm gonna go with the first
place I really love that appetizer oh
the mini calzone I wouldn't call it that
it was more like a savory pastry
delicate little dough pocket filled with
tomato sauce cheese and seasoned meat
just a stunning culinary innovation it
was a calzone it was literally just a
small calzone
Chris I'm dying I was dying earlier
today and then I died no I'm dead I had
to cancel a date with shauna
malwae-tweep
I really like her do you think just like
me dead what is this it's food poisoning
I have it too I did not sleep for one
second last night and I cracked the
bottom of the toilet oh god don't say
that has anybody talked to Tom I can't
even imagine but that tiny little man
must be feeling I have voided more than
Tom's body weight in the last 12 hours
alone he might have just disappeared off
the earth we need to call him must reach
out to him I can't do it Ben extension
78 20 smells like some vomit took a dump
in here what happened we got food
poisoning Tom how do you not have food
poisoning because you didn't eat
anything just take pictures and talked
about the wow factor
not you I ate everything you did are you
sure is there anything that you didn't
eat oh yeah I didn't eat those stupid
mini calzones have her food rule number
six never eat anything with the sauce
have to dip myself drizzle it on for me
I'm not your maid
the calzones betrayed me never again
guys as God is my witness they're dead
to me alright well Tommy feels great and
I'm about to go eat some lasagna please
you